so many people outwork me I still make  more money than that one of the things  that grinds my gears is this whole like  no one can outwork me Mantra why are we  bragging about work because work has  very little to do with the highest  levels of the game in order to do  anything you must do something The  Leverage that we have on that activity  is going to dictate how much we get out  of it and if we do a low leverage  activity many many many times we might  get more than a high leverage activity  that gets done once but with enough  leverage one move can do more than  thousands of low leverage activity moves  so for example The Rock makes a tweet  and says hey guys I just started this  new X he will get more leverage from  that one activity than somebody who DMS  a thousand people or ten thousand people  there are many ways to win the game